sup bTW welcome to the high pass I'm
Thomas let's get a tour alright this is
the crew my name is Nick Austin my
name's chase Hudson when we first moved
in we didn't have furniture or lighting
and the only lighting we would have
during night time would kind of be our
bathroom lights and everyone filmed in
here people would come over and just
would kick it and when we didn't have
furniture there's really no place to sit
so people just sit on the countertops
and on the on the bathtub and everything
there would be like 3040 people in this
bathroom at one time well over a
thousand tick-tocks have been made in
our bathroom in the first like two
months of living here now downstairs
there's probably been like five hundred
made down in our living room but um but
when we first moved in everyone would
just come in here you'd wake up to
people being in here you'd go to sleep
with people going in your bathroom
turning on the lights and filming but
every day we invested in getting a lock
on our door so no one knows the code and
we got ring lights for the whole house
so people don't have to come up here
anymore we have to be here for people to
get in the room and to get in the
bathroom it wouldn't let me in there
tick tock so make this one blow this is
our bath right here this is our goose
his name is Jerry we take baths in here
sometimes I've actually never taken a
bath in there once
okay that's false I suppose we took one
in there we were doing a coke and mentos
challenge we've filled it up with coke
so what better way to use a nice bathtub
than to pour coke inside okay over here
is my sink
and this is my ring light these are our
lights in our mirror it's very big and
this is our green marble I think it is
countertop is our shower has two
showerheads Thomas's sink he also lives
here and about it and here is a toilet
and a bidet I'm not going to show you
because that's nasty and that's pretty
much little bathroom
I'm a Bonnie Brett oh we've already
donut shop I'm desi Keach you guys I
just realized something my dog's teeth
are straighter than mine to our kitchen
over here we have a stove that we do not
use we have some pile of dishes that we
do need to put away and apparently this
is the fridge kind of a cabinet but it's
fridge and it doesn't smell very good
and there's like nothing in there really
it's like some hot sauce and cookie
dough won't bring up postmates straight
into here and then we'll just kind of
hang out and eat like sit on the
counters or whatever but really we kind
of hang out everywhere like it just kind
of depends where everyone is already set
up like there's no specific spot that we
hang out anymore used to be the bathroom
but we kind of stopped ahead and now we
just kind of hang out wherever we can
find a seat three four ovens that's kind
of cool secret compartments like watch
whoa so you can hide your food so no one
takes it that's the trash compactors
that's what you call it
I don't really open it you put it up in
there in it means that small I used to
cook in here when I first moved in here
but then it got really difficult through
the dishes because no one really cleans
up after themselves so I don't even
remember last time I cook who's a better
cook hi guys I'm Alex Warren this is my
baby no okay you're tiny this is barb
this is cope by the way my awesome
girlfriend um so a little bit thing
about our room is we've always wanted to
have a dream room in a way kind of like
we're somewhere where we feel really
comfortable and this is kind of the
vision that we thought out so for
starters our cat has a hotel we spoil
her is this stormy by the way
and this is her little hotel we're
planning on building like a whole entire
thing with wood planks - then she can
run around the entire room like was
helpful total rain really high really
high she will jump on top of the
cabinets and just sit up there oh my god
if we always entertain people in this
room so like anyone in the house it's
kind of like the comfortable clean room
that everyone just plays video games at
so I bought a Nintendo switch we all
come in here and make popcorn with my
popcorn machine it's hang out on the
couch edit do what we want to do in here
and it's really very comfortable like a
big air B&B I've got you want anything
to drink read I've got Girl Scout
cookies I bought a ton what's your
favorite we have a California king-size
comforter
every night I managed to have one foot
of the blanket he will wrap himself up
in a burrito and then blame it all on me
yeah I do that I know I do that
Tovah and I are planning and pulling it
on later oh and then over here I just
recently started liking shoes so like I
just have like a little shoe collection
I hear some cool shoes I thought I'd
like and then the mini fridge we just
have a bunch of energy drinks and Girl
Scout cookies in there and then we just
have a bunch over that - this is Alex's
closets I bought all the hangers though
I love the crazy aspect that's my
blogsite and that's my job to film the
crazy but um I like getting away and I
like to have my own like privacy in a
way and this is like our little private
room
I'm very extra - so it's just a bunch of
like aspects of this room that I really
love like behind us I've always wanted a
cool studio like something to do like I
edit all my own YouTube videos so it's
actually a lot of people wonder why I
have security cameras because it's not
like a traditional thing to have in
someone's room I have it because
sometimes I will miss content it's like
my job is to film my life and my friends
so when my friends were here at 3 a.m.
and I hit my bed and they're just
messing around I remember the other day
Calvin and patty started like wrestling
with each other I didn't get any of it
on film because my camera was right
there and I was in bed so then I went to
my security camera I was able to catch
everything that was but happening and
then I used it my vlog and kind of did a
story times we built this just because
it's like we've always wanted an
aesthetic pleasing kind of thing
everyone feels comfortable and the
ability to have all these starting
nights and lights is just something that
I've always been interested in it makes
the room more homey
[Music]
it's not just a group of friends I
literally treat it like family you know
we argue we fight we have our
differences but at the end of the day we
all go to bed and we still love each
other we started this as a group of
friends to make content to have a good
time to do something that no one else is
doing and it's working out really good
and it's really fun and they were making
a business out of something that we've
dreamed of doing alright guys thanks for
coming by I got to make sure these kids
get to work make some tic TOCs
I'll see you guys next time
[Music]